the five most amazing moves of American
wizard wizard at the chessboard Hikaru
at Nakamura Hikaru The Legend of online
chess one of the best blitz players ever
and we're now going to take a look at
sparkling moments sparkling moves that
he has played can you predict Hikaru
smooth make sure you like and subscribe
to the channel now otherwise the ginger
beard will come after you I'm having a
little bit of a you know Christmas
hangover at the moment so I need to I
need to cheer myself up and he car is
gonna do that you know to me in this
first example Hikaru has the black
pieces against the legendary player
Boris Gelfand Hikaru's Queen is being
attacked and he's played a very
aggressive Kings Indian defense a
favorite opening of Garry Kasparov
amongst others and Bobby Fischer a hero
of I'm short a clarinet mural now what
move in this position did he carry you
play a really shocking yet beautiful
idea can you spot it I wouldn't say this
is too easy to get you started but I
think some of you guys and girls will
get it Queen to be free so what are
those moves you just want to slide along
the board I don't screw into the square
then look at your opponent and say I'm
rather clever aren't I
and this move threatens checkmate by
capturing on air free and it's really
distraction idea as well because both
the Queen and the bishop can be taken
but if the Queen is taken g2 is now left
undefended and Bishop to g2 is checkmate
this is the main idea and if the bishop
is taken Queen takes f3 also needs to
check me girlfriend tried to fight on
with Knight takes e5 but now he Corey
played a lover lovely move Bishop takes
f1 leaving the Queen on pre because the
g2 Square is the main aim and Hikaru
simply won a piece by capturing on c3
and went on to win a very nice game and
if you do want to check out some of her
car is over brilliant victories in the
Kings in defense go and check out some
of my premium videos on the chess calm
sites where I look at a number of his
King Zealand Defence victories on to
example number two in this next sample
whites is Hikaru and he's playing
against X feed a world champion
ponomaryov from Ukraine and the black
king is stuck in the middle of the board
and white is also exchanged up but the
next move is a beautiful way to keep the
attack going can you spot the rather
surprising idea that he karu now
unleashed upon his opponents come on you
can do it
Queen takes e5 and this is a beautiful
way to try to get rid of this F port
because now if the queen is taken you
can see that rook is no longer blocked
by pawn and Bishop to h5 check leads to
checkmate next move
look at those beautiful rooks on the
open files where they belong and this is
very nice little tactic he Corey wanted
sharp his tactical plays around nowadays
without a shadow of doubt and after
Kings who have seven in the game he
Corey's attack ranged on with Queen to
g3 in this next example Corey's a very
strong opponent Chris Senko has just
played Bishop takes f6 releasing the
rook on the Queen now this might look to
be rather tragic here Kaoru but Hikaru
had seen that little bit further that is
why he is the new American wizard
maybe Fabiana will have something to say
about that but he's he's certainly a
tactical mastermind and what move now
did he car replay which led to a
beautiful attack and try to calculate as
far as you can from this moment on so
you might see the first move but just
try to visualize how it will continue
the attack Queen takes f2 their attack
the rocket launcher comes in and this it
basically draws the White King out into
the open King takes and now Bishop to c5
check dominating bishops Kings we're
three had the King gone backwards then
the other bishop would be released with
this move c3 and look at those bishops
they're like
cannon balls aiming at the White King
after Kings we're free the attack
continues and we just got to keep
checking and creating threats now rook
takes f6 check King to g4 Knight to e5
check the White King can't survive in
such an open and exposed position King
g5 rook g6 check King h5 and now a star
move here
pawn to f6 sometimes it's the quiet
moves in the midst of the battle which
really Sparkle and really are the
magical moments and this quiet move sets
up checkmate threats with rook h6 for
example rook takes e5 the only way to
avoid that but now the rook comes in and
again we see a beautifully quiet yet
deadly move here Bishop to c8 really
really beautiful idea stopping the White
King from ever retreating threatening
rook checkmates and there's nothing
that's white can do here so white ends
up resigning beautiful stuff let's move
on to another sparkling moment from he
carries plate
well it's next move there's a little bit
of a bolt from the blue I'd say the
black king is water exposed and he
carried with the white pieces now opens
it up further maybe quite a I say you
know easiest tactic to spot you know you
can be the judge of that what move did
her carried out play Bishop takes h7 and
the reason I picked this maybe it's not
one of the most sparkling and beautiful
moves you've ever seen but in my eyes is
very thematic and it still requires some
very precise calculation now the main
idea is to bring the rook into the
attack and the reason it's formatic is
often when free pieces are attacking a
weak King it will lead to checkmate a
little bit of a vise well worth
remembering after Queen takes h7 route
to f5 now threatens rook to h5 and
there's not much black and do here
because the knight is also attacked rook
g8 tried Queen to f3
and now the tactical thing that really
he kind of must have seen in advance and
hopefully you guys saw in advance of
Isis whole sacrifice doesn't quite jell
rook g5 what you play rook takes g5 and
Queen to f8 winning the night leading to
a winning position this is a key thing
you must have seen right from the outset
did you see that didn't see it maybe you
shouldn't be played Bishop takes h7 in
the first place should you calculation
is king the reason I love this position
here is because it's basically Hikaru
saying to Magnus whatever you did I did
before you they're kind of rivals Hikaru
Magnus Magnus getting the better of her
Kaoru but can you remember my previous
video on Magnus Carlson's five most
amazing moose and the move that gave him
the world championships now if you want
to get better at chess it's about
remembering patterns and what is the
move here black to play and to boom
explode the board with a lovely
checkmate my dear can you see it Oh
Queen takes a free check and this is a
lovely way to force checkmate I don't
know if you can call it a sacrifice
because it's checkmate next move but
it's exactly the same kind of idea that
Magnus Carlsen did to become world
champion but Hikaru did this I think in
2002 so well before Magnus Carlsen
whatever you do Magnus I did before you
just remember and next move the rook is
gonna go to a one delivering checkmate
whatever white plays King takes rook a
one checkmate pawn takes rook a one
checkmate very very nice play remember
to like this video and subscribe to the
chess comm channel hopefully I can get
some more videos out for you guys and
leave your comments below and please do
tell me which of these five moves you
enjoyed the most did you see all the
moves
did you don't cheat I'll come and get
you
yeah I'll give you a pound the back
anyway yeah Cheers until next time bye